a friend of mine recently asked his
priest the best way to pray and he said
most people pray out of fear most people
pray when they want something or need
something he said but the most effective
prayers are praying with gratitude this
Thanksgiving is a great reminder to be
grateful for what we have in a world
filled with tension and strife it is
more important than ever to just feel
and express our gratitude for the things
that we do have I'm grateful for my
family I'm grateful for the people
around me who love me and want me to be
my natural best and I'm grateful to you
the people out there are helping me
build a vision in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do I am fully aware that
the only reason that this movement is
moving is because we're doing it
together so on behalf of the optimism
company behalf of all of our optimists
here thank you thank you thank you have
a very very Happy Thanksgiving